She's the chief financial officer of one of
the biggest telecommunications equipment companies
in the world.
Now it's emerged that Meng Wanzhou has been
in custody in Canada for days.
US authorities appear to be seeking her extradition
on charges of helping Huawei violate the U-S
trade embargo against Iran.
Further details of the allegations against
her are still unknown.
But her arrest comes as Huawei faces increasing
scrutiny from abroad.
In the past, U-S lawmakers have described
the company as a threat to national security
- saying its technology could be used for
spying.
Other countries, like Australia and New Zealand,
share those concerns and have banned Huawei's
equipment from being used in their high-speed
5G mobile networks.
Huawei has repeatedly denied those claims.
When news of Meng's arrest broke, China's
embassy in Canada released a statement saying
it "firmly opposes and strongly protests"
the move.
The arrest comes at an especially sensitive
time in US-Chinese trade relations.
Last weekend, the countries' leaders agreed
to a 90-day truce in their months-long trade
dispute.
The U-S decision to target one of China's
most important tech giants is only likely
to reignite tensions.